Curtis Horn, by the way, thanks for your question, bro.
He said, I have tried concrete, now trying spray foam.
I'd like to give a couple of others niches to try as well.
Are masonry and artificial grass good candidates?
So here's the deal, you know, masonry,
I've made a decent amount of money in masonry,
so I would say yes, artificial grass is the same.
Artificial grass, I would go out on a limb
and say it's probably been tapped a little bit
because it's the thing that we use for the training.
And artificial grass isn't like concrete
where it's done every single location.
So artificial grass, you're gonna find deals,
but you're gonna have to look a little bit harder,
but it's a good niche and so is masonry, okay?
So yes, yes to both.